you have a special that that you're
promoting and in this special you talk
about many things you talk about
something that sounded kind of
intriguing I don't really know anything
about it
couples colonics yes my wife is from
Santa Monica and that's you know a
vestige of being born and raised in
Santa Monica's you believe that colonics
are a good thing and and yeah she tried
to tried she did she company to go on a
couples colonic it's it's a it's a
terrible terrible idea and and and I
went you know kicking and screaming into
it and why would a couple do it together
it sounds like a medical procedure
it doesn't sound Kody that is my point
exactly it's not like it's it's not like
you're getting massages side by side and
there's like some sense of romance
you're getting a she thought she
honestly to her credit she truly thought
that we were going to be laying on these
you know like massage table beds you
know hand in hand looking each other in
the eyes honey I love you but you know
like that was her concept there's
nothing here that appeals at all she in
her defense she did think it would be
funny and she said that like come on you
get a bit out of it but something my
wife has never said to me let's do
something weird and comedic that you can
maybe talk about later I mean she's
never ever said that it was it was an
awful traumatic experience that I will
never repeat